well we have a variety of controls of
course the the the main mode of control
has to do with our degree of knowledge
and understanding of the world as you
change how you what you know about the
world you change how you're going to
control your perception for example and
and you also learn about what you want
to pay attention to and what you don't
so that those are very important very
important aspects and you can create
techniques that sort of technique is
probably a little bit too much but you
you you create strategies that allow you
to filter things that you don't want for
example right now in order to pay
attention to what you're asking me and
to pay attention to what is going on in
my mind I'm trying to filter out things
that are happening around me that have
to do with the lights that have to do
with the technicians and and so on and
that's part of the control and then
there's a level of control that I would
like to describe with the word the
liberation and which has to do with
something that you don't do online you
do actually offline when you rather than
perceiving the outside world you sort of
step into yourself into your mind space
and you you imagine what is I mean you
reimagine what is happening you consider
a problem you analyze how the problem
can be solved you think about options
and so on everything that we normally
described as higher-level reasoning
decision-making and creativity you know
these are processes that cannot be done
online they're done offline but of
course have an enormous influence on how
the brain is going to work now
to have an influence directly on how the
brain is firing neurons right now that's
a very different story of course there
there are ways of influencing it with
states of altered perception some that
are in the or control like say different
kinds of meditation and some there are
whether the control of say medications
drugs whatever but that's really about
it so in other words the the control is
considerable when you think about say
long-term goals the way you react to the
world you can construct guidelines for
how you would desire to operate how you
think it's ideal and try to institute
that and then you have ways in which
they char sort of probably less
effective in which you just control what
is happening on the moment like trying
to curb an excessive emotional reaction
or something of the sort